Fick dich weg, du Robo-Fürst!
Fick dich weg!
46 euro was ist das für ein scheiß preis da kriegst ja schon vierer mit mindestens
2g für ja ja aber 20 euro sind schon in ordnung kann man schon machen
ja bei starlink bin ich ja immer gespannt was da rauskommt also ich bin ja da ein bisschen
skeptisch erstens wegen dem ganzen schrott den es da potenziell gibt und ob die bandbreite
für viele user reicht also es muss ja es reicht ja in dem fall bei starlink reicht
ja nicht nur bandbreite aber von a nach b oder irgendein fettes untersee kabel oder
sowas das muss ja quasi ich sag jetzt mal ganz so p2p von sattelit zu sattelit zu sattelit
zu sattelit so durch dieses sattelit mesh durch bis es dann runter geschickt werden
kann also da habe ich so meine zweifel ob das so wahnsinnig gut funktioniert wofür
wofür starlink aber auf jeden fall richtig gut funktioniert von den übertragungsgeschwindigkeiten
ist wie heißt high frequency trading weil du bist schneller von new york nach europa
oder sonst wo durch starlink satteliten als beispielsweise durch den untersee kabel rein
latenz technisch habe ich am anfang auch nicht gedacht aber ist anscheinend so also
im prinzip ist das wieder was für big stonks starlink
ich habe uns auch mal patronen gesehen am himmel also heute gehe ich davon aus dass
das drohnen sind das war bei uns so ein bisschen wenn du wenn du ein bisschen weiter raus fährst
das sind relativ viel felder und sowas dann bin ich auch immer lang abends und da sind
auch so 8 leuchtende dinger am himmel angeflogen das könnten auch aliens gewesen sein aber
ich tippe eher darauf dass das drohend war
er hat im stream erklärt na dann ob es ein eigenes funkt protokoll ist weiß man nicht
an der endstation was auf jeden fall stink normales multicast udp
okay ich habe nichts übersehen exzellent also nur mal so für die erklärung was wir
heute fertig machen wir haben ja gestern ich zeigte es ich zeigte es mal schnell ich muss
mich erstmal ordentlich hier an computer setzen ich sitze ungefähr ich weiß gar nicht ob
ich da ob es irgendwie so ein bild zugibt also ich sitze gerade irgendwie so eineinhalb
meter weg vom computer und es guckt im prinzip nur mein kopf über dem schreibtisch raus
und jetzt mal übertrieben zu sagen dass ich ich ich hänge so halb unter dem schreibtisch
grad ich wusste ob ich erst erst mal aufstehen so exzellent ja so ok alles klar jetzt noch
mal da alex de dankeschön für den sub ich ich interpretiere das mal als alex verliebt
speak der alex wahrscheinlich sitzt du so da ne also ungefähr so sitze ich nicht da
aber ähnlich ich habe kein bein hoch ich habe die beine also drunter komplett wollen
wir nicht den video angucken nach gestern noch wo sie ich wo sich lilos irgendwie drüber
aufregt dass der des den lilox des top so sagt ich meine es ist da von 2014 aber wahrscheinlich
sagt es immer noch ich meine lilox auf dem desktop sagt halt auch es ist halt zumindest
nix für den 0815 loop was macht moment moment bevor wir anfangen was sagen denn so die aktuellen
battlefield leaks was audiospur zum trailer aufgetaucht aufgetaucht das ist ein witz oder
zumindest der trail was zum die wollen nicht ernsthaft jetzt links ja genau das habe ich
gelesen vorhin und da geht es um die audiospur der nächste liegt zu battlefield 6 lässt
uns den reveal trailer hören meine güte die haben echt probleme trailer audio trailer
leak alter das das was ein schwachsinn der discord habe ich gestern ich was ein schwachsinn
haben echt probleme jetzt nicht mehr normal die liegen sich den bobs wund er und wisst
ihr was das was der witz ist wisst ihr was der größte witz bei der ganzen sache ist
das sind überhaupt keine leaks im klassischen sinn das wird garantiert alles das lässt
garantiert alles ea durchsickern das ist taktik das hat mit leaks gar nichts zu tun es sei
denn ein leak ist neuerdings wenn ich absichtlich in ein loch reinschneide und dann was raus
läuft das darling sucht gerade cdn engineers das brau man braucht man da braucht man da
gute englischkenntnisse für es geht bestimmt auch ohne oder we are all sitting in one boat
ich glaube ich glaube das geht bestimmt auch ohne so also was wollen die dann haben senior
content distribution network engineer achtung leute flash bang bla bla bla basic qualification
bachelor degree da da da kommst nicht weiter mit einer fisi ausbildung bei space x 5 plus
years experience 5 plus years of working in cross fun functional hardware software operation
teams was hast du alles für chrome plugins quasi kaum welch ich hab was hab ich hier
uploc dark reader ffz das allerwichtigste addon und so komisches addon um die lautstärke
zu steuern preferred skills master degree ok wie gesagt also mit der fisi ausbildung
ist da nix hier an der stelle ffz denn das ist das dass du die ganzen dass du das zum
beispiel so was hier sehen kannst in im twitch chat bei dir steht wahrscheinlich einfach
nur flash bang da in wirklichkeit ist es ja ein emote
naja das ist das ist nix für kack noobs
das ist das ist nix was ist denn der gemat score was ist denn der gemat score alles ist
wie gut man was kann ok da siehst du mal die wollen schon gescheite leute haben ja so als
kack noob muss man sich da nicht bewerben veteran status
so mit ein bisschen so mit ein bisschen shit repo und fisi ausbildung ist da nix wie funktioniert
das mit dem windows deno switchen du drückst control windows rechte feiltaste und control
windows linke feiltaste da kannst du durch die du hast noch hier unten verschiedene desktops
und die kannst du so durchschalten und du musst einfach auf deinem zweiten windows desktop
eine vm mit linux haben und dann funktioniert das schon easy und um nicht zu sagen wir machen
genau da weiter wo ich gestern aufgehört habe exakt deswegen zeige ich jetzt auch nochmal
gestern zu stehen geblieben sind stand da c++ experience wirklich von ks bei space x wollen
es aber wissen ich dachte die dependents in java script bei space x ich habe das kanal
punkte sammeln gar nicht an ja könnte ich es ist die frage was du damit machen willst
was hast du denn vor weil da ganz hängt es ja ganz entscheidend davon ab wie leistungsfähig
du was brauchst also was ich dir also die einstieg ist natürlich ein raspberry pi ich persönlich
empfehle low power intel x86 hardware weil es einfach noch ein bisschen mehr wumms hat
nicht wirklich so viel mehr strom brauche und meistens noch ein bisschen flexibler ist
was man damit machen kann ansonsten wenn du richtig können auf ebay gucken wenn du was
richtig dickes brauchst kannst du beispielsweise nach alten dell server oder hp server sind
es ja suchen da gibt es dann schon die ein oder anderen dickeren dickeren teile müssen
aber halt gucken was es für eine ist der hier ist jetzt relativ alt was hatten der
hier drinnen cpu prozessor typ nicht zutreffen naja gut das bringt natürlich gar nix muss
dir schon fertig fettische kaufen da absolut nichts sagen was das jetzt hier sein soll
server shop kannst du ja da war ich mal kurz davor mir was zu kaufen vor zwei drei jahren
habe ich dann aber nicht gemacht ich kling nicht gesund echt nicht warum merkt ihr was
was ich nicht merke
stimme ist safe anders wirklich sekunde moment das muss ich mir jetzt anhören ob das wirklich
so ist echt kling ich so bla bla bla test test test test test test ja ja ich habe gepennt
vorhin eine runde nach mittagessen aber bla bla bla bla bla bla bla test test test test
wie anders als sonst klingt es doch auch nicht
das hier hat jetzt ein pr für analytics auf github ok guck mal die die die die bieten
hier auch dl3 80 dl3 18 recht nice mir mir mir kratzt auch schon so im hals was haben
die hier dann zu bieten drinne zweimal inter xeon acht core das heißt du kriegst 16 kerne
16 geram das ist doch schon mal ganz gut bittel teuer vielleicht das ganze dann lieber so
was hier alter das ding schaut aus was kommt war wo hat das gestanden ist das die gesamte
artikel beschreibung gibt es da nicht noch mehr dazu ja also wenn du power brauchst kannst
du danach suchen die sache ist halt die du musst auch ein bisschen auf den stromverbrauch
achten also es hat keinen sinn also wenn du die leistung brauchst klar aber ansonsten
hat es keinen sinn sich übertrieben fette kisten daheim hinzustellen bloß weil das
eigentlich im einkauf jetzt ebay billig ist aber dann doppelt so stromrechnung hast ja
genau also ist halt die frage was du machen willst ja das kommt drauf an was man machen
will also du hast ja lokal versus aws immer den vorteil dass es halt nur lokal ist sprich
wenn du dann passport safe hast oder deine heimautomatisierung oder sonst was dann ist
das lokal halt einfach schöner als in aws also ich würde zum beispiel ein passport safe
nicht öffentlich in aws hausten zumindest das wäre prudent für meine heimautomatisierung
würde ich auch nicht in aws hausten weil ich will dass die lokal funktioniert ohne
internetzugang ja die dinger sind richtig fett und und die ältere 80 gen 5 gen 5 ist
noch der mit mit den mit diesen roten sachen vorne ja ja genau mit den mit den roten festplatten
wechseldingern und so kommt halt drauf an das ist immer die frage was man machen will
genau hier hetzer code immer noch am start also ganz ehrlich wenn du wenn du noch nichts
großartiges vor hast dann würde ich dir empfehlen hol dir sowas hier musste aber mal gucken
was es da aktuelleres gibt hol dir sowas hier hol dir irgendwie sowas hier in der richtung
irgendwie sowas da bekommste für 80 euro muss man mal gucken was der kram hier gerade
neu kostet 90 euro da bekommste für 90 euro eine low power plattform die braucht 8 watt
im eidl 4 cpu kerne und das ist immer noch schneller als den raspberry pi und es ist
x86 und du kriegst noch einen pc express slot das ist finde ich eine echt gute plattform
für zum einsteigen daheim das kannst du auch in ein x-beliebiges alles gehäuse schmeißen
wie gesagt du musst da am anfang erst mal gar nicht so viel geld ausgeben
weiß gar nicht was das ist eine thinkstation ah das sind diese griffe das mit dem griff
zum wegschmeißen von ibm eh linovo was ist der lila ne port das ist ein parallel port
ich mein sowas kennt man heutzutage nicht mehr das ist auch ziemlich antik aber das
mainboard hat allen ernst noch ein parallel port und ein serieller port also serielle
schrittstelle ne moment das ist vga ne leute ich bin verwirrt das ist vga und das ist serial
oder oder umgedreht keck weight ne ich glaube das hier ist serial das ist parallel das ist
vga was ist eigentlich von honey was hä was soll das sein weiß ich nicht sagt mir nichts
ja aber das ist zum einstieg auf jeden fall ganz das mit den exposten pins also das hier
das blaue blau ist seriös seriell jetzt mal wieder boomer boomer time wer von euch hat
null mode im netzwerkverbindung gemacht über serielle schrittstelle gibt es überhaupt
noch leute die wissen was das für pains champ bedeutet oder serielle null mode im kabel
über parallel honeyball das ist garantiert werbung oder das ist einfach nur gut getarnte
werbung 100 pro keck weight echt haben paar gemacht na immerhin immerhin ja für isdn anlagen
musste das auch man das war auf jeden fall für die damalige zeit richtig poggers da weiß
ich noch wir haben damals sachen geschert über parallel port null mode im kabel das
da hat dann quasi ne half life 1 installation mit allen mods hat dann erstmal 3 stunden
kopiert das war ja nicht schnell ne du konntest richtig windows netzwerk machen glaube über
parallel port so richtig ip windows netz über parallel port ich weiß so wir haben damals
dateien geschert über windows da muss es dann netbios und so pains champige sachen anmachen
wer hat noch ide festplatten gejumpert ach das haben glaube ich noch einige gemacht das
war noch ein bisschen länger also das hat man noch ein bisschen später gemacht als null
mode im kabel echt die firmware updates kosten gehen mittlerweile nur noch mit mit offiziellen
mhp account na dann keck weight throwbjörn deine chatnachricht wurde vom automod geploggt
weil du hast geschrieben jab und jab wurde erkannt als rassistische anspielung auf japaner
hat der automod gerade gesagt also hier ne anzeige ist raus der ist glaube ich nicht
für deutschen chat ausgelegt der automod da hat lust jetzt jetzt ging es durch jetzt
ging es durch warum auch immer das vorher nicht durch geht keine ahnung so leute wir
machen jetzt mal weiter wartet mal irgendwie plus delta deins wird jetzt auch auch geploggt
leute ich bin übelst irgendwie noch nicht noch nicht richtig wach ich weiß auch nicht
ich hätte nicht ich hätte keine stunde pennen sollen nachmittag essen aber ich war so voll
gefressen ich habe wieder big brain nudeln gemacht hier da habe ich wieder nudeln bestellt
vor einem monat die haben absolute pains champ webseite aber das essen schmeckt richtig
geil nudeln moment da da habe ich vorhin eine packung also haben wir also nicht ich alleine
eine packung vorhin gefuttert und da war ich so pepo fett danach da war ich so müde da
musste erst mal eine stunde pennen zumal ich heute schon stunde eineinhalb stunden sport
gemacht habe heute morgen ja man kann es kaum vorstellen so ich muss jetzt mal hinstellen
hier und wach werden dass wir was machen können hier was ist denn hier los bringt es leute
ich habe jetzt hier neben mir mal hier flex flex champ aber ihr wisst dass ich dafür
kein geld ausgegeben habe ich habe jetzt hier neben mir liegen ein iphone 6 ein iphone
xr und ein iphone 11 ihr wisst ja ich bekomme so ein von der firma ein dienst handy und
irgendwie war gestern in der post ein iphone 11 drinne so nach dem motto ich soll mein
xr durch ein iphone 11 austauschen ok mache ich warum nicht nicht dass es schlecht gewesen
wäre oder so ja aber die kann ich übrigens iphone 12 kriegst du wahrscheinlich erst ab
vorstand keine ahnung übrigens die kann ich euch echt nur empfehlen die nudel von
denen das einzige problem ist dass die halt relativ teuer sind ich meine guck mal hier
bezahlste 14 euro für sechs packen jeweils 500 gramm also das ist irgendwie erst mal
80 prozent teurer als die lidlnudel aber die schmecken auch 80 prozent besser als die lidlnudel
wenn nicht mehr als 80 prozent besser als die lidlnudel gab es keine bessere schriftdaten
als times new roman ohne scheiß die website ist ist hardcore pains champ wenn du hier was
wenn du hier was bestellen willst dann klickst du auch nicht auf in wahrenkorb hinzufügen
sondern drückst hier hinten auf eins dann musst du runterscrollen da musst du auf den
wahrenkorb genau runterscrollen und dann kannst du hier nochmal wenn du mehr bestellen willst
zwei reinschreiben dann musst du hier aus jetzt ist richtig pains champ die seite ganz
ganz grausam aber das essen schmeckt echt gut starmack sechs monat dankeschön für
den zapp oh nee ist das ist das ein asp asp.net 6 oder was ist das ok das ist das ist das ist
echt pains champ ich server pages 2002 ja ok so sieht die seite auch aus als ist die von
2002 asp webforms ja grausam richtig also ein also ein kaum größerer pains champ möglich
in der webentwicklung so leute ich zeige euch jetzt mal kurz was wir gestern gemacht haben
also ich habe gestern im stream gezeigt wie man das hinkriegt wenn man eine domain hat
wohlgemerkt man muss eine domain besetzen dafür sonst geht das nicht es muss auch keine
kostenpflichtige domain sein es kann auch irgendeine kostenlose dac dns oder sonst
wie domain sein man braucht eine domain und ich habe gestern im stream gezeigt wie man
kostenlos let's encrypt zertifikate gültige let's encrypt zertifikate bekommen kann für
services die nur lokal laufen guckt hier zum beispiel das da ist ein service keck keck
ww der läuft nur lokal und wenn ich die seite aufmache dann geht es nicht wahrscheinlich
weil mein dockercontainer stills abgekackt ist durchs vmw starten gucken wir mal ob es
jetzt geht immer noch nicht ok wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen wenn es immer noch nicht
geht erst mal eine runde rebooten da geht es bestimmt wieder mach mal ein hat request
wohin soll ich ein hat request machen 5 hat request das ich finde also in htp 3 oder gibt
es es schon ja also jaja klar da sollte nicht nur hat request drin sein sondern 5 hat request
das wäre schon besser um zu zeigen wie modern das ganze ist so jetzt mal gucken in welchem
ordner war ich in gestern hier keck weight war ich im keck weight ordner keck weight
ja meine ordner sind ja immer so gut benannt dass man gleich bescheidbar ist ok da sind
wir ok also ihr seht wir haben lokalen service laufen der nur lokal erreichbar ist ihr seht
wenn ich den ganzen wenn ich den ganzen krempel pinge hier lokale kiste wird aufgelöst ihr
könnt bei euch daheim probieren also ihr könnt keck ww maupunkt tausend nicht auflösen
die domain habe ich mir mal gekauft also deswegen habe ich auch zugrebe auf den dns und wir
haben gültiges zertifikat denn gültiges zertifikat für drei monate das ganze läuft
am 5 gestern ausgestellt läuft am 5 august ab so so siehts aus chat ist eh schon drin
mist ah zu spät nicht aufgepasst habe ich critical information geleckt dein geburtstag
ja da läuft das zertifikat aus so und macht gerade mal visual studio auf wo genau hängts
ip geleaked monka es omg ip leak fack so und das ganze haben wir natürlich weil wir next
level big brain defops stealth machen müssen wobei der richtige next level wäre natürlich
dass wir das nicht von hand alles starten sondern dass wir noch irgendwo eine github
github actions oder irgendeinen continuous deployment haben was das ganze dann natürlich
auf unsere kupanetes cluster deployed in aws also wenn schon wenn schon dann richtig
ja also wir haben das ganze lokal laufen und zumindest haben wir die defops lite variante
gemacht haben das natürlich alles auch ins shit repo eingecheckt und damit das ganze besser
läuft im shit repo haben wir auch noch ein frontend dafür aufgesetzt und zwar shit shit.com.haws
da haben wir hier in den repo mit docker compose im docker compose fall sonst ist da nix nix
drinne so und jetzt machen wir weiter an der stelle eigentlich wollte ich nämlich noch
zusätzlich das war so der auffänger der ganze geschichte noch einen password manager installieren
weil es gibt paar sachen die leute fragen mich immer was hältst du davon das ganze
ist übrigens bitwarden rs früher das mussten die umbenennen weil die glaub irgendwie
hat mich nicht lizenzprobleme oder so oder oder abmahnung oder keine ahnung sie mussten
sich zumindest umbenennen und da wäre ich oft danach gefragt was hältst denn davon
gucken wir uns jetzt mal an wir haben uns das vor drei jahren oder so schon mal angeguckt
aber da hat es bestimmt einiges getan ihr wisst ja dass ich den key pass fan bin seit
wann ich sie umbenannt habe seit ungefähr einem monat
war bieber du kannst das irgendwie nicht richtig mit den emotes das ist das richtige emote
hacker man du kannst aber auch wir haben auch wir haben auch ein richtiges subscriber hacker
emote
ich habe ich habe hier key pass key pass 2 bitteschön ja ja habe ich mir auch schon mal im stream
angeguckt fand ich relativ gut die habt recht ich habe irgendwas im hals ihr habt das schon
gehört bevor ich das gemerkt habe habe ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt dass ich prioritätsgruppe
3 bin für die corona impfung also warum auch immer mein arbeitgeber war der meinung ich
bin wichtig für kritische infrastruktur deswegen muss ich prioritätsgruppe 3 sein bin mir
da ehrlich gesagt persönlich jetzt nicht so sicher ob ich wirklich wichtig bin früher
kritische infrastruktur weil bei uns geht es immerhin nur um geld und nicht um menschenleben
aber gut geld ist natürlich das wichtigere sind wir also so in der heutigen zeit stonks
größer menschenleben ja natürlich natürlich deswegen habe ich mich angemeldet jetzt mal
gucken wann ich einen termin krieg heute morgen habe ich im radio ja ich weiß boomer medium
und so manchmal habe ich zum frühstück noch noch radio an haben sie erzählt jetzt wird
der impfturbo gestartet wie der aussieht habe ich nicht genau verstanden aber der turbo
ist jetzt wird gestartet das wirkt für mich wie so typische management aussage wenn man
eigentlich nichts neues zu vermelden hat sagt man halt mal irgendwas was zur b ne das
passt nicht das wort radios richtig boomer ja so nachdem wir jetzt unser unser git repo
haben mit der mit der docker kompost konfig mit kündigsten zertifikaten da gibt es jetzt
auch ein paar sachen die wir machen müssen um unseren passport safe zum laufen zu bekommen
als erstes müssen wir hier ein eintrag für den passport safe machen und dann sollten
wir noch zusätzlichen eintrag machen dass die docker container regelmäßig aktualisiert
werden weil ich habe es ja schon gesagt also man sollte darauf achten dass man immer einen
ordentlichen tag beim image dabei schreibt also wenn wir jetzt noch mal auf docker hub
gehen und jetzt nehmen wir mal beispielsweise hier den den container den wir gleich installieren
wollen da muss man sich immer einen passenden tag raussuchen weil ansonsten machst du deine
container einmal neu und hast komplett andere versionen die sich vielleicht mit einer konfig
nicht mehr vertragen also das ist keine allzu gute idee man sollte sich immer einen ordentlichen
tag raussuchen am besten ist natürlich ein tag der noch security updates bekommt und
in dem fall ist es hier nicht version 1.14 sondern die versionieren das so also es ist
die version 1.14 so und dann gibt es security updates gibt es dann beispielsweise sowas
und die bekomme ich zusätzlich auch wenn ich diesen tag hier verwende natürlich kann
man auch einfach latest nehmen so wie shana mäßig macht hat man ein paar probleme damit
aber wir nehmen jetzt wir können für walvarden auf jeden fall erstmal latest nehmen zum ausprobieren
wie man das docker file deploit du checkst dein git repo aus und sagt docker compose ab
auf einer neuen kiste fertig das war es ich meine du kannst natürlich auch irgendwelche
git hooks oder sonst was machen aber gibt es irgendwie jammel wieso was gibt es dann jammel
großartig nicht zu verstehen das einzige wo du bei jammel drauf achten musst ist dass
du den kram richtig einrückst das ist das einzige du musst den kram richtig einrücken
sonst geht es nicht also das hier ist kein gültiges jammel das hier schon für den jammel
eigentlich ganz angenehm wobei ich sagen muss nee ja ok stimmt die umfrage gestern gesehen
haben haben wir wobei ich ja persönlich jason tatsächlich angenehmer finde wobei man sagen
muss ich weiß nicht ob ihr das ob ihr das weiß wisst wahrscheinlich weiß dass jeder
aber ich denke nur dass ihr das nicht weiß weil boomer gedanken und so das jammel quasi
ein erweitertes jason ist auch wenn es komplett anders aussieht also gültiges jason ist auch
automatisch gültiges jammel also ich könnte ich könnte hier beispielsweise auch ohne
probleme glaube das da schreiben also dass das das funktioniert aber jason hat so ein
paar probleme also mir fehlt ehrlich gesagt nur ein feature in jason sonst würde ich
es für alles verwenden dass man kommentare rein machen kann das geht nicht es gibt es
gibt in jason keine keine comments die man machen kann jason genau das das wird mir
eigentlich schon reichen weil auf dieses ganze jammel einrückungszeug habe ich jetzt persönlich
auch nicht so wahnsinnig bock man kann auch tommel verwenden ich war ich finde es halt
doof dass es schon wieder so zig verschiedene sagen kannst inny verwenden du kannst jammel
verwenden du kannst tommel verwenden du kannst jason verwenden kannst xml verwenden also
nie kann man das nehme ich zurück man kann xml eigentlich nie wirklich verwenden was
gibt es sonst noch so csv csv ist eh das beste so richtig schön richtig schönes richtig
schönes csv oder so was da ja exquisite so ein richtig schönes csv da geht doch eigentlich
nichts drüber sag doch mal so richtig schönes gut lesbares csv na txt ist ja kein kein
format in dem sinn ist einfach plaintext wir haben auf der arbeit auch noch ein paar csv
in dem die im einsatz sind manche leute kommen bei uns auf der arbeit sogar noch die glorreiche
idee host also hostlisten in csv zu machen so aber jetzt fangen wir mal an also wir müssen
unser passport safe drinnen einrichten wir wissen jetzt ja dass es ohne probleme funktioniert
zertifikate anzufordern neue services anzulegen es ist kein problem by the way ich muss mein
token ich leake wieder mein aktuelles token moment moment ich habe nämlich das token
von gestern gelöscht ich habe das token von gestern gelöscht ich brauche neues token
ja neues token schon wieder token leak token leak aber ich habe es wieder so eingeschränkt
dass es nur von meiner absender ip geht so also dann legen wir mal den service für unseren
bit vault vault vault warden an bit warden vault warden also ich finde bit warden geht
deutlich einfacher von der zunge also vault warden das liegt aber wahrscheinlich einmal
nicht vorhanden englisch skills du kannst nf nutzen für token ich kann auch einfach
den secrets ich kann auch einfach die die secrets geschichte von von docker compose
verwenden aber wozu das token fliegt eh direkt nach dem stream wieder weg
ist es nicht der token das ist eine gute frage der token das token der oder das token korrekturen
punkt e also pfeiffer time activated leute der die das token moment moment in seiner ursprünglichen
wissenschaftlichen behördung ist das token eine definierte abfolgung von zeichen blitz
das maskulinum der token wird hingegen verwendet wenn man damit eine methode oder eine schlüssel
zu identifizieren von alternatifizierung ja dann ist in dem fall das token doch richtig
ist instinktiv haben wir es richtig gemacht chat big brain time das liegt einfach an
den vielen prime subs letztendlich ist es aber auch egal wie man es nennt die meisten
leute verstehen sie was mich immer leute eine frage eine frage die ich bis heute nicht beantworten
konnte die auch immer irrelevanter wird weil die software keiner mehr verwendet aber vielleicht
kennt ihr noch jemand die monitoring software nagios so wenn man jetzt wenn man jetzt eine
nagios instanz hat ist das ist das ein nagios so und wie ist die mehrzahl davon nagios nagi
nagina ja was ist ist die mehrzahl ein nagios zwei nagios mit dahinter automod hat dein
comment geplogged weil es zu viel ähnlichkeit zu einem anderen wort aufweist zwei agile
nagios nagios aus weilspanisch weiß ich nagios mehrzahl
ok wir müssen plural dabei schreiben dann wahrscheinlich besser
das heißt es ist ein nagios zwei nagios da kann ich da kann ich mich nicht damit anfreunden
letztendlich werden wir dieses problem heute aber auch nicht gelöst bekommen deswegen
machen wir jetzt mal weiter also wir brauchen wo wo wo was ist denn hier los wir brauchen
eine instanz von unserem passwort manager im moment wald worden heißt das ding jetzt
warum löscht der automod heute alles vielleicht weil kein richtiger mod da ist vielleicht
ist er nicht so nicht so aggressiv wenn ein richtiger mod da ist keine ahnung kann ja
sein das zeug ist ja mittlerweile alles heute massive brain so also was für einen was für
einen tag verwenden wir dann wort waren latest latest einfach wir suchen mal nach einem example
extra ja compose example vielleicht muss man nämlich noch auf mehr sachen achten an die
ich jetzt gar nicht denke so compose wiki using docker compose kommt mal die haben tatsächlich
einträge wie lange streamst du heute abend noch mal oder erst früh es ist ja schon fast
abend also da haben wir doch ein beispiel für wie das ganze funktioniert also immer latest
natürlich natürlich immer latest was sonst latest restart always das lasse ich das lasse
ich eigentlich immer weg servicers haben nicht zu crashen wieso benutzen die ein fork die
benutzen kein fork was meinste wer benutzt den fork das ist das offizielle das ist das
offizielle repo ach so ach jetzt ach jetzt habe ich verstanden weil der offizielle bid
warn server wohl ziemlich pains champ zu sein scheint und früher ist das projekt ja bid
warn rs und wahrscheinlich haben die sich umbenannt auf drängen des ursprungsprojekts
schitt repo ja da muss man mit das video zugesehen haben dass man es versteht wir hatten
mann azubi der hat gett ausgesprochen wie schitt endpunkt geht es gut mit dem habe ich letztens
telefoniert der macht jetzt richtig big brain geschichten so ok volumes so also jetzt müssen
wir mal ans angucken haben die hier vielleicht in traffic example drinne haben die vielleicht
in traffic example wo ich mir einfach mal kopieren kann ob es irgendwelche besonderheiten
gibt hier proxy examples traffic thoughts what the fuck wollen die mich verarschen was
das das brauche ich doch zur hälfte alles gar nicht das brauche ich doch eigentlich
alles gar nicht richtig wupp weh ist das ich mach das ich mach das jetzt mal ich mach das
jetzt mal selbst ich mach das mal selbst das braucht man alles nicht also pw safe kriegt
das ding als url entry ist web secure zertifikate stellen wir über die normale dns challenge
aus laut balancer port das ist die frage ob wir da überhaupt eine laut balancer port
brauchen auf welchem port läuft es denn standardmäßig
machen die denn hier laut balancer 3.012 wer nimmt denn standardmäßig 3.012 ach nee ah
das ist für die websocket verbindung port 80 ist der normale ok dann müssen wir hier
port 80 nehmen
so und das sollte jetzt eigentlich websocket können wir rausschmeißen das sollte jetzt
von der theorie erreichen also was der jetzt machen sollte ist hingehen ein neues zertifikat
ausstellen für pw safe was übrigens schon auf die richtige ip auflöst weil ich das
in meinem dns eingetragen habe da löst auch nur lokal auf halt alles auf die gleiche ip
aber das macht ja nix der sollte jetzt hingehen sich ein gültiges zertifikat ausstellen lassen
für pw safe und dann sollte der auf port 80 reverse proxien soweit von der theorie her
gucken wir mal ob er das macht
ok er lädt sich erstmal das image runter das ist das ist ok das ist genehmigt
browser auf gucken uns das an
ok schauen wir mal ob er sich jetzt ein zertifikat ausgestellt hat pw safe noch nicht noch nicht
scheint brauche er noch ein bisschen für
der hau mich plau das habe ich nicht mal selbst gemacht das war glaube ich der der
chainlord die katze ausgestellt wo ist jetzt das problem warum hat er sich kein zertifikat
ausgestellt ah doch jetzt macht das oder jetzt macht das ich muss einfach nur ein bisschen
warten pw safe wait for prop ja einfach nur kurz abwarten bis er das passwort sich ausgestellt
hat dass das das zertifikat sich ausgestellt hat ok passt jetzt jetzt sollte auch das passwort
gilt was habe ich ein passwort alter das zertifikat gültig sein da ist er ja ok warum auch immer
die so ein komisches gedöns machen es scheint mir ehrlich gesagt relativ easy zu sein einfach
einfach so wie man es erwarten würde laut balenzen und gut ist schieben wir es mal auf
dritten desktop so jetzt ist die große große master passwort was weiß ich was ist denn
die default passwort davon man muss ja mit irgendwas einloggen schreibt er das vielleicht
auf die konsole irgendwo gibt es nicht ja wie soll ich mich denn dann anmelden wenn es
es nicht gibt noch gucken von dem ding nee ah moment passwort nee kein passwort du musst
ein account erstellen ok das heißt der erste account der erste account ist dann gleich
der admin account ok muss das gültig sein das ist ja das master passwort ok muss wahrscheinlich
nicht gültig sein so create account ok immer adresse cute chat ad egal ich hoffe das muss
keine ich hoffe das muss keine gültige email adresse adresse sein your name alles klar
passt passwort 1 2 3 4 5 6 mal gucken ob auch wie was das ist doch best practice passwort
was will er mir erzählen seit wann ist das ein weakest passwort hint dahinten ist natürlich
lulw größer kekw ich agree zu den terms of services submit ok dann ist mein neues
master passwort 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 wie das ist immer noch weak wie
kann das weak ok das ist strong so jetzt aber 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 submit weak master passwort
wie gesagt millionen leute können sich nicht irren login 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 login zack da
sind wir in your face hat funktioniert unser passwort ist auch am start und das schöne
ist jetzt um das nochmal hervorzunehmen warum das setup äußerst äußerst praktisch ist
wir haben ein gültiges zertifikat über let's encrypt obwohl der service nur von innen
zu erreichen ist also sprich wenn ihr bei euch jetzt daheim das hier auflöst wird das
nicht auflösen das ist eine super geschichte ich meine man braucht das nicht unbedingt
über htps aber wie gestern schon gesagt manche krypto sachen im browser gehen nur mit htps
und gültig im zertifikat web rtc gehen manche sachen nur htps und gültig im zertifikat
und spätestens wenn du eine anwendung als pwa verwenden willst auf dem smartphone da
geht das auch nur mit htps und gültig im zertifikat also so unsinnig lokal das zu machen ist das
nicht hast du das video von gestern als wort klar ist er doch hier guck also ob es schon
ob es ob es immer schief ist weiß ich nicht ob es schon immer schief ist aber aktuell
ist es auf jeden fall hier noch auf youtube wir können mal gucken ob es immer schief
ist oder im archiv wie das die coolen leute dann sagen such wie wo sind die streams ich
blick in meinem archiv dann mal durch hier da ok das ist noch nicht drinnen oh leute
wir müssen archiv wo ist das hier baro der cute mod der cute mod muss hochladen sonst
sind die so sind die streams ja verloren ich meine ich habe bei mir auf ich habe hier nur
noch zwei klop es eineinhalb oder zwei monate videos haben wir hier nur drinnen also das
letzte video was ich hier drinnen habe ist vor zwei monaten oder müssen wir uns aber
ein bisschen sputen jetzt also wir bedeutet jemand anderes wir müssen den cute mod mal
nerven im discord dass er das wieder aktualisiert ok also das hat funktioniert bevor wir uns
jetzt näher mit dem passport manager beschäftigen sollten wir erst noch mal natürlich so richtig
big brain defops stylish natürlich erstmal ein neues kommet machen also geht kommet
das ist an sich nicht so schön dass wir die eigentlichen daten da drinnen liegen haben
also es wäre beispielsweise schöner wir würden den unterordner dafür machen oder
wir machen den data ordner und den data ordner packen wir dann ins geht ignore oder sowas
in der richtung das könnte das könnten wir eigentlich noch machen jetzt das machen wir
jetzt noch weil das problem ist jetzt wenn ihr das hier deployen wollt oder wenn ihr
wenn ihr das kommetten wollt ihr habt immer im gleichen verzeichnis irgendwelche untracked
files rumliegen das ist doof ja nicht dass sie die da aus versehen mal committed wenn
ihr die aus versehen committed ist doof weil dann ladet ihr eventuell eure password save
auf github hoch das ist nicht so schön und gut ohne master passport bringt das nichts
aber man will es vielleicht trotzdem nicht und geht mark binaries nicht so sehr also
wir könnten jetzt beispielsweise mal den ordner anlegen keine da macht es mal aus
data da machen wir ein git ignore file und sagen hier diesen ordner lasst mal in ruhe
jetzt sehen wir auch schon der taucht hier drinnen gar nicht auf und jetzt können wir
diesen kram beispielsweise auch mal verschieben in den data ordner was permission denied
cake wait gut tut gut data so da ist es jetzt müssen wir hier noch ändern wo er das findet
data slash slash so und jetzt sollte das ganze funktionieren wenn ich das richtig gemacht
hab ja sieht gut aus erfindet sein kram wieder er hat das repo wiedergefunden alles gut alles
richtig gemacht und jetzt haben wir den vorteil wir können ich werde es jetzt mal anders
machen bei warum hängt jetzt eigentlich jetzt manchmal binaries in git immer gut zu binaries
in git fällt mir lustige geschichte ein ganz zu anfang als wir noch selbst nicht wussten was
wir damit getrieben haben sind wir mal auf die glorreiche idee gekommen java updates also java
runtime updates ins git einzuchecken und die sind ja immer so 200 300 mb groß oder teilweise
sogar 700 und irgendwann war unser git repo 2,5 gigabyte groß und jedes mal wenn du das git repo
geklont hast hast du hast du irgendwie fünf minuten gewartet bis es durch war und ein nachteil hat
das ja du kriegst es nie im leben wieder raus also hast du eine sache einmal eingecheckt in
dein git repo und gepusht du kriegst es nicht wieder raus du kannst also ich meine mir ist
selbst klar dass es theoretisch möglichkeiten gibt aber die sind alle nicht praktikabel vor allem
nicht wenn es über ein jahr her ist und du da quasi ab diesem zeitpunkt die komplette history
umschreiben ist es ein force push alleine bringt ja auch nichts du musst alle verknüpfung entfernen
die irgendwo in diesem git repo existieren und da musst du den git git clean oder so was glaube
ich machen und das ist gar nicht so einfach das sagt richtig also du musst genau genau also das
das ist nicht wirklich praktikabel wir haben es dann einfach anders gemacht wir haben die ganze config
die ganzen configs einfach in neues repo kopiert und das mit binaries eingelassen
es war eine blöde idee damals wir haben wir haben sogar software updates und adressdatenbanken und
sowas da eingecheckt deswegen es war am ende glaube sogar größer als 2,5 g das war keine
so clevere idee zumindest was wir jetzt machen können ist erstmal das git ignore enden so und
jetzt kann man quasi dieses ganze repo klonen auf eine neue kiste docker compose abmachen und
man hat exakt die gleiche config die wir hier lokal haben wieder hochgefahren auf dem anderen
rechner und da sieht man auch was der ursprüngliche gedanke dahinter war einer der ursprünglichen
ideen dahinter ist dass man wenn man software entwickelt und abhängigkeiten davon hat oder
oder gewisse gewisse services braucht zum testen dass man die sich damit starten kann so dass jeder
entwickler quasi das gleiche oder ungefähr das gleiche hat das war so eines der ursprünglichen
gedanken hinter dockercontainern also dass die leute dann auf die idee gekommen sind docker
container in produktion mit sich stinger laufen zu lassen das war nicht im sinne dass er des
ursprünglichen gedankens und erfinder kann man machen aber das war nicht die ursprüngliche idee
dahinter die ursprüngliche idee war dass man selbst content anwendung verpacken kann und
abhängigkeiten dazu sodass du da nicht beispielsweise drei verschiedene libraries hast weil die weil
deine drei entwickler unterschiedliche betriebssysteme verwenden und sowas so geht
er docker compose und wenn man jetzt ein kommet macht ist ganz wichtig dass man ein gutes dass
man ein gutes gutes gutes geht kommet macht und ein richtig gutes geht kommet bei beispielsweise
an der stelle wäre jetzt sowas wie feifert zum beispiel das zum beispiel ganz gutes kommet
da weiß jeder was gemeint ist wenn er das liest das würde ich euch wärmstens ans herz legen sowas
zu machen als kommentare und ich mein besser als meine geht kommet ist so wie geht ja eigentlich
gar nicht ich meine wir haben kommet feifert komplett kommet in it also wer damit nichts
anfangen kann dann weiß ich auch nicht ja und wenn man das ganze gepusht hat in das shit repo
ja die adresse ist nicht liegt das ist die öffentliche adresse auf dem channel und da
wo auch die paypal donations draufgehen da ist nichts liegt und wenn einem dann doch einfeld
haben ist ich hätte das doch lieber gern anders genannt ja oder oder sagen wir mal so es fällt
einem vielleicht ein man hat sich hier verschrieben man wollte hier unbedingt noch ein lehrzeichen
mehr hintendran machen und sagt geht natürlich es gibt eine änderung und jetzt und jetzt passt
auf jetzt sagen jetzt einfach wir hängen an das letzte kommet die aktuelle änderung noch dran
und ändern die kommet kommet message noch dabei jetzt haben wir es geändert jetzt ist es gatchi
bus aber das problem dabei ist was man jetzt hier auch gleich sieht was man zu bspw. zum
beispiel bei meiner schelle in diesem prompt mit den zwei feilen sieht was man jetzt sieht
ist jetzt können wir nicht mehr so einfach pushen wenn ich jetzt versuche zu pushen dann sagt
er mir das geht nicht und warum geht das nicht naja guckt euch mal meine lokale historie an das
sind die drei kommets lokal und guckt euch das mal remote an das sind die drei kommets remote die
passen nicht zusammen das heißt er erlaubt mir so jetzt nicht ohne weiteres zu pushen weil er
sagt hey da würdest du ja was überschreiben das kann man fixen indem man einen force hintendran
macht in der regel und das ist aber so 95 prozent geschichte ausnahmen bestätigen die regel in
dem fall macht man das nur auf eigenen branches nie auf öffentlichen branches also mit öffentlichen
branches meine ich branches die andere leute auch verwenden also man kann das zum beispiel
machen wenn man wenn man an irgendeinem feature bastelt macht man sich den eigenen branch und
wusste dann da drinnen rum und macht dann ganz macht dann 150 kacke kommets und am ende macht
man mal ein paar ordentliche draus ja und force pusht das dann und macht pull request das ist ok
das hier ist in der regel äußerst schlecht weil mal angenommen der chat wir haben jetzt 270 zuschauer
also mal angenommen ihr hättet jetzt auch dieses repo ausgecheckt und ich würde das hier jetzt
machen da wären alle eure repos kaputt kaputt in der form dass ihr keine updates mehr pullen
könnt man ihr könnt natürlich dann das ganze selbst beheben ja das geht aber erste mal ist
euer repo dann kaputt zumindest das zum upstream funktioniert nicht mehr deswegen öffentliche
branches oder branches wo mehrere leute mitarbeiten nie force pushen das bedeutet auch nicht irgendwie
historie umschreiben aber wir sind die einzigen die daran arbeiten wir können das jetzt machen
wir sehen sie auch hier ist noch das letzte kommet fife hat und wenn ich die selbst überschreibe ist
das letzte kommet gachi buss das versteht außerhalb von twitch auch keiner ich dachte so ich dachte so
als wäre das das normalste von der welt so nach dem motto hier sehen wir das letzte kommet fife hat
und jetzt das nächste kommet gachi buss so wie das normalste von der welt nächste kommets gachi buss
ja und auch wenn man sich die historie anguckt sieht man hier ist nichts mehr von meinem kommet
übrig aber und jetzt zeige ich euch mal den massive hugest githack life hack aller Zeiten
was macht ihr denn jetzt wenn ihr feststellt mist in diesem kommet was ich eben überschrieben
habe war noch was wichtiges drin was macht ihr dann ich mein hier ist es nicht mehr
hier ist es auch nicht mehr wo ist das kommet eine schöne sache an git ist es ist immer noch
da es ist immer noch da alles was euer lokales repo je gesehen hat ist in der regel immer noch
da es sei denn ihr habt es explizit weggeschmissen aber das macht man normalerweise nicht so und es
gibt eine sache die ist in git nicht so offensichtlich das wissen viele nicht aber es ist eines der
praktischsten sachen überhaupt und zwar ist das git reflog da sieht man nämlich das ist quasi
eine historie für alle aktionen die man lokal in seinem git repo gemacht hat ich weiß nicht wie
wie lang die historie standardmäßig ist ob es dann limit gibt weil aber in der regel ist die
lang genug sollten ihr seht guckt mal da da ist das kommet noch und wenn ich jetzt wissen will wie
war denn der stand oder ich brauche noch was aus diesem kommet da kann ich ganz einfach einen
check out darauf machen man kann in git alles auschecken du kannst kommets auschecken text
ausstecken und branches auschecken unter der haube sind das eigentlich alles nur zeige auf
kommet ideas und jetzt habe ich wieder den stand den ich vorher hatte zumindest jetzt temporär
und ich kann sagen ok was war denn hier noch mal das was ich brauche kommt mal hier das habe
ich gelöscht das kopiere ich mir jetzt raus oder sowas man kann das ganze auch diffen geht auch
damit man allerdings wohl nicht allzu viel sehen außer dass es hier zwei leerzeiten hinten dran
gibt so und auch ein kommet was ich persönlich sehr praktisch finde was kein kommet in kommand was
ich auch sehr praktisch finde ist get cherry minus fau was da oder was da muss man nicht
weglassen get cherry minus fau get cherry minus fau ist quasi ein diff plus also ein kommet
basiertes diff nur ein bisschen übersichtlicher und zwar das zeigt dir ein komplettes das zeigt
dir kein komplettes diff an was sich geändert hat zwischen den branches sondern das zeigt dir
welche kommets in diesem branch drinnen sind oder in diesem working tree drinnen check out drinnen
sind und nicht in dem branch mit dem bloß vergleicht das ist sehr praktisch das brauche
ich auf der arbeit täglich zum beispiel um zu gucken ob es bei einem feature branch sachen gibt
die noch nicht gemercht wurden es gibt nämlich leute bei uns die machen beispielsweise in den
feature branch da machen sie dann merge request auf dann machen sie von diesem feature branch
einen neuen feature branch auf mit einem anderen feature wurde es dann noch mit teilweise sind
sie ein bisschen unordentlich ja und da bin ich dann öfters mal hier am gucken so nach dem motto
haben wir denn schon alles gemercht kann ich diesen kommet in kram jetzt wegschmeißen und da ist das
hier das beste kommand für du siehst alle kommets die hier drinnen sind aber nicht im master
was zum hänke ist das für eine sprache was was he vanilla ist vier monate dank ich für den
sub excellent massive subscription so ich glaube das hat man jetzt halbwegs verstanden aber das
also wie gesagt reff noch könnt ihr euch merken das rettet einem den s wenn man aus versehen mal
was gelöscht hat rechts das ist gar keine sprache das ist jammel das sind jammel config file für
unsere container wieder was gelernt siehst du genau ich lerne ja auch fast jeden stream was
so aber hier den ganzen krempel mal zu
ach so was war mein master password 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so haben wir wieder was gelernt
excellent gut ja was gibt es denn sonst jetzt noch schönes dazu zu sagen also wir sollten
noch wir sollten noch eine sache machen wie gesagt wir sollten uns hier in den ordentlichen
tag aussuchen weil das ist immer ein bisschen problematisch kannst du grob erklären wie das
mit traffic umgesetzt hast ja ich kann es dir zeigen das ist relativ easy dass sie ist eigentlich
alles egal wichtig ist das hier du musst dem sagen dass du dns challenge machen willst für
letztendlich dann musst du ihm sagen welchen letztendlich provider du verwendest in dem fall
das cloudflare plugin und da musst du eine umgebungsvariable suchen mit einem api key von
deinem cloudflare das war es im endeffekt mehr musst du nicht machen dass letztendlich funktioniert
ich mein es muss auch kein cloudflare sein das kann name cheap oder was auch immer oder
irgendwas sein irgendwas was es halt unterstützt so und dann habe ich ihm gesagt er soll
standardmäßig einfach alle docker container aus diesem compose file standardmäßig gucken ob
es da ob die domain gemapt haben und dafür sich ein zertifikat abrufen das war es mehr
musst du nicht machen also das ist tatsächlich relativ einfach allerdings muss man sagen für
advancedere sachen ist die traffic konfig schon sehr pains champ meint ihr wie lange bis ich
das hier gecheckt habe dass man wieder rekt machen kann automatisch von htp auf htps ich
meine da kommt doch niemand drauf dass das die richtige syntax dafür ist oder also die haben
sich die haben sich schon ein bisschen das leben schwer gemacht also die traffic konfig ist nicht
ist nicht so schön wann würdest du die konfig auslagern gar nicht wozu soll die konfig auslagern
das schöne am docker compose file ist ja dass alles drin steht was du brauchst du kannst das
einfach rüber kopieren auf den anderen rechner und starten und es funktioniert bei traffic musst du
für manche sachen musst du eine extra konfig datei anlegen zum beispiel wenn du services load
balancen willst die nicht in diesem docker compose fall drin stehen ich glaube dafür brauchst du
dann eine extra extra traffic konfig aber die ist richtig pains champ
ich bin auch kein allzu großer traffic fan muss ich sagen ich benutze das nur hier im
im im zusammenhang mit so docker compose geschichten für andere sachen würde ich
nicht verwenden ich persönlich mag katie für einfache sachen wo man nix großartiges war
advancedes braucht und wenn man was braucht was alles irgendwie kann dann nimmt man nimmt man
den engine x es gibt ja manche leute die schwören heute immer noch auf apache load balancer aber
da bin ich mir nicht so sicher ha proxy kann man auch nehmen wobei ha proxy eher load balancer
aber man im prinzip kann sie damit auch alles machen so genau jetzt können wir uns mal den
password manager angucken kannst du die docker compose irgendwie veröffentlichen
kann ich machen ja kann ich machen machen einfach mal ein paste bin weil viel viel kompliziert
das ist da nicht dabei das lohnt sich keine extra git repo zu machen ihr paste bin so was
ich mache ich mache mal meinen token raus also erstens funktioniert es von euch aus
ähnlich zwar ins löschen das nachher wieder sonntags highlight jamme jara was ist denn
jara ich habe mal gehört dass auf türkisch ja ja rack oder ja rack heißt schwanz stimmt das
hört mir der kratzer auf bei der gelegenheit woher ich das weiß ist folgendes der friseur
also fabian der hat ja immer eine gewisse namens kombination in mmos und das ist meistens
irgendeine abwandlung von jia ja ja oder sowas in der richtung und er hat sich mal einen männlichen
charakter erstellt in einem mmo und er hieß ja ja rack ein bisschen anders geschrieben und
irgendwie haben die leute laufen angeschrieben und was mit schwanz erzählt bis bis wir dann
irgendwann drauf gekommen sind dass der name auf türkisch schwanz bedeutet ich glaube seitdem
hat er seinen schad nicht mehr so genannt theoretisch hätte er für sogar tempen bekommen
können ok also ich veröffentlicht den kram war schnell ich meine die domain kommen ja die
domain ich kann es einfach drin stehen lassen ich mein domain können wir auch so was hier
reinschreiben domain.domain.de aber wie ich das einfach drin stehen oder einfach xxx yy
ok kann man das irgendwo exposure unlisted bam zack also wer es haben will da ist es
so jetzt können wir uns den password manager mal widmen und uns das ganze mal anschauen
also wir haben uns das vor einem jahr oder nee ist länger her vielleicht zwei drei jahre
haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt und ich muss sagen ich fand das ganz gut wie gesagt ich
verwende seit jahren ja schon key pass und ich sehe jetzt ich weiß man kann das irgendwie
da auch importieren aber ich habe jetzt noch keinen großartigen kund gesehen das umzustellen
im browser brauche ich es nicht aber wir schauen mal was man damit alles machen kann also add
item das haben wir hier schon alles ok credit card identity secure note ok notizen kann
man auch speichern das ist schon mal ganz praktisch also haben wir mal login zum beispiel für
keine ahnung für google folder brauchen wir nicht username peter agil et google mail.com
keine ahnung ob das die richtige also password 123456789 oder so wahrscheinlich wieder so
wie ich mich so wie ich mich kenne ah guck mal der kann direkt authentificator app sünden
das ist natürlich cool kannst du es auch einfach auf deutsch stellen das weiß ich jetzt müssen
wir gleich mal gucken so was ich praktisch finde ist dass man notizen dabei machen kann
weil gerade wenn man zwei factor authentifizierung drinne hat dann ist das immer ganz praktisch
dass man die recovery codes hier reinschreiben kann er ist das center of excellence er arbeitet
nicht nur da da sieht sich nach wie vor als agila enabler für cloud native solutions save
was ist totp das ist das was du bei authentifizierte apps verwendest diese dinger hier also wo du
die qr code scannst wurde deine authentifizierte app passt die den code anzeigt na es gibt
zwei sachen das was du meinst ist zwei factor mit sms es gibt aber mittlerweile auch schon
sich authentifizierte apps ja microsoft authentifizierte blizzard authentifizierte steam hat glaube
ich auch so ein ding ach so man kann in settings kann man die sprache umstellen können wir
machen also ich würde es persönlich auf englisch lassen aber weil ihr seid wir stellen das
mal um language auf de ist es nicht ge nicht german ok 1 2 3 5 7 8 9 so mein trisor haben
wir jetzt mein trisor so massive für was ist das häkchen hier da kann man alles verschieben
und so was so wie editiert man das jetzt benutzername kopieren passwort kopieren ok nice silver
dark dankeschön zehn monat als subscription wie kann man es bearbeiten ach hier einfach
draufklicken ok ja das ist nice und jetzt müssen wir natürlich mal gucken ob es dann
browser add-on für gibt oder sowas was man sinnvoll verwenden kann neue uhr ttps genau
ok mal gucken ob der jetzt automatisch das ausfüllen will wenn ich auf google gehe also
bit worden chrome ne das ist ein firefox oder ein mal chrome fire das in chrome hat es jemand
schon verwendet also was nimmt man die offizielle browser extension für du benutzt docker haben
wir noch 2014 wir gucken uns gleich stimmt wir wollten uns noch ein konferenz talk von
2014 angucken gleich was verwenden denn die coolen leute heute also für so einfache anwendungszwecke
jetzt kommt mir keiner irgendwie mit mit mit kuppe mit mit asher kubernetes klasse cluster
oder sowas an krio ok container dies ok krio sagt mir gar nix krio ich dachte die coolen
leute verwenden potman also potman ist schon wieder out oder die coolen leute vor einer
weile haben alle gesagt potman beste weil kein root und sonst wie
man aber container die ist doch mittlerweile auch einer docker standardmäßig drunter oder
ja firecracker firecracker kenne ich das ist das zeug von amazon das ist nicht von amazon
das ja genau genau das kenne ich
aber ich muss ja ehrlich sagen für so einfache dinger also vier services starten lokal da
ist mir docker compose und docker immer noch mit abstand am liebsten das funktioniert einfach
und ist easy ich meine ich will keinen dran hindern sich 16 raspberry pies lokal irgendwie
zu verteilen und in super agilen kubernetes cluster da aufzuspannen wenn er das will kann
er das ruhig machen wir wollten auch mal einen lokalen kubernetes cluster machen im stream
es gibt so viele sachen eine zeit lang gab es mal ko es gibt es ja nicht mehr ko es heißt
jetzt ja flat car weil man sich dort gerne umbenennt ko es ist out jetzt gibt es flat
car ich sag doch ich sag euch leute doch bei also im container umfeld da irgendwie halbwegs
up-to-date zu bleiben ist fast schlimmer als im javascript umfeld das ist was achne das
nur der tracker und javascript aktuell zu bleiben ist schon nicht nicht ohne so also
password manager bittest den da add to chrome alles klar add extension bitworn extension
install so und dem kann ich jetzt irgendwie einstellen dass er youtube comments search
was hat man da jetzt alles wie sage ich dem denn jetzt da was der für was der dafür
verwenden soll ich habe das noch nie verwendet ich muss ihm doch irgendwie sagen können
dass der mein lokalen passport selbst verwenden verwenden soll ne settings ah hier ok settings
ist das da genau bin ich jetzt mal gespannt wie gut da wie gut er kam funktioniert settings
lokaler server das da mehr muss ich noch nicht machen oder einfach so save login was
habe ich denn für den habe ich ja noch mal genommen ja ja mein konto hier cute chat
lpw safe alles klar alles klar ja meine gütig kann man doch den ganzen krab nicht merken
den ich da so eingeb ok login 8 9 enter bäm da sind wir nice ok jetzt funktioniert sogar
die browser extension sehr cool jetzt gucken wir mal ob er das auf google ob er das auf
google eintragen will wie funktioniert das ich habe das noch nie verwendet wir sagen
dem erstmal er soll die extension anzeigen ach komm mal erkennt dass wir auf der webseite
sind zeigt er jetzt alles ah guck mal da macht der auto kommt was control shift i suchte jetzt
da nur die sachen raus die mit google was zu tun haben ach l ok das ist mir sogar lieber
als autocomplete ja so jetzt gucken wir mal was passiert wenn ich jetzt noch einen anderen
eintracht hinzufüge wir machen es noch mal einen anderen eintracht keine ahnung youtube
keck weight at das da ist ja egal so und jetzt hier youtube.com das heißt wenn ich jetzt
hier drauf bin dann zeigt er mir auch kein kram von youtube an ok das ist cool das gefällt
mir so sprich wenn ich jetzt hier drauf klicke weiter weiter ha stimmt nicht gut ich habe
ja auch müsste eingetippt alles klar das ist schick das gefällt mir das hat was so
wenn ich jetzt auf youtube gehe schlägt er mir da den kram vor wobei youtube login ist
ja youtube login ist ja gba das ist ja google sign in bekommt man den auch in home assistant
integriert inwiefern was willst du da integrieren mal gucken ob es eine integration für gibt
es gibt es gibt einen addon dass du das einfach starten kannst ok was willst du da was willst
du da großartig integrieren
ach so du meinst ob du aus deiner home assistant config irgendwie auch die passwörter zugreifen
kannst bestimmt irgendwie aber dass das damit zu verheiraten weiß ich nicht ob das so sinnig
ist das weiß ich nicht aber ich mein du kannst ja eine extra secrets datei machen in home
assistant und die checkst du halt nicht mit ins kind ein aber du kriegst das bestimmt
irgendwie integriert ja aber wüsste ich jetzt entweder kein plan alter lan max hast du
mit warn oder mit warn s installiert ich habe wollt warden installiert echt haben wir das
gemacht ich habe das gar nicht mehr ver gar nicht mehr verfolgt das kann auch relativ
schnell passieren deswegen am besten die dinger gar nicht da reinlegen oder gleich als erstes
einen git ignore eintrag erstellen ich habe ja secrets eigentlich nie im git repo liegen
also gar nicht im gleichen verzeichnis nach möglichkeit wofür das wofür das das lokale
gemacht ist naja dass du musst ja irgendwo deine passwörter speichern die extension greift
ja nur auf diesen also also die extension hier im browser die greift ja nur auf das
auf diese sache hier zu ohne das würde die extension nicht funktionieren es gibt ja irgendwo
eine suchmaschine die explizit dafür gemacht ist dass du github github durchsucht nach
irgendwelchen secrets also wenn du aber wenn es ohne missleute wenn man nach wenn man nach
github geht und dort sucht nach irgendwelchen bekannten environment variabler machen wir
doch mal machen wir uns doch mal den spaß machen wir uns doch mal den spaß und suchen
nach cfdns api token in github so und wir werden hier garantiert irgendwo fündig
leider bin ich nicht eingelog das heißt ich kann keine codesuche machen das ist ein bisschen
doof ich müsste codesuche machen können ich bin ich eingelog auf auf shit hab bin ich
hier eingelog ne auch nicht ja dann weiß ich nicht also du wirst garantiert garantiert
wirst du es wirst du es finden einfach mal google also github ist voll und das problem
ist wenn du es einmal gepusht hast du kriegst es eigentlich nicht wieder wieder wieder
aus dem internet raus du musst es löschen und ein neues api token generieren ne aber
das browser addon finde ich wirklich cool ich mein sowas gibt es für keypass auch
aber es macht sicherlich einfacher wenn das ganze in den webservice ist auf der anderen
seite ist ein webservice halt auch wieder einfacher darauf zuzugreifen als eine lokale
datei ne selbst force push kriegt die sachen nicht zwangsläufig wieder weg ich hab hier
grad hast ja grad gesehen im stream ich hab ja sachen force push gelöscht und es war
noch da kann man da eigentlich noch verschiedene typen anlegen was ist denn cent es gibt keine
sense aufzulisten sense was ist ein cent text lull copy link to share this center was aber
es ist irgendwie sowas was achso ja gut das bringt ja nur was wenn es öffentlich ist
ne das bringt ja nur was wenn es öffentlich ist da könnt ihr ja nach wie vor nicht drauf
zugreifen da kann man sachen scheren wenn wenn man was so was öffentlich hat ok ja
das kann man machen aber ich würde also ganz ehrlich ich würde niemals auf die idee kommen
mein passport safe egal wie sehr ich den traue irgendwie ins internet zu stellen klar das
mag alles noch kleinseitig verschlüsselt sein ohne passport kannst du damit nichts anfangen
es ist ja nicht so als hätte das backender drauf zugriff hoffe ich mal zumindest aber
es würde ich nicht machen das einfachste irgendwelchen sachen vorzubeugen ist es einfach
also problem vorzubeugen ist einfach nirgendwo hinzulegen wenn es nirgendwo liegt kann damit
auch keiner irgendwas machen wenn man das natürlich natürlich ist das nur gültig
wenn man es alleine verwendet sollte man das jetzt beispielsweise mit der familie zusammen
verwenden oder von unterwegs verwenden wollen oder vielleicht sogar irgendwie in einem
kleinen team so ein passport safe verwenden wollen dann ist das was anderes ja aber nie
übers internet also ich würde es nie übers internet machen ehrlich gesagt vpn nach hause
ja das das das finde ich noch ok das werde ich würde ich noch ok finden wenn man sich
erst per vpn einloggen muss aber ich hätte trotzdem so meine bedenken also wie gesagt
ich verwende seit jahren schon key pass und ich habe keypass gesüngt auf zwei rechner
fertig das liegt nirgendwo ich habe ich habe meinen key pass hier auf dem rechner und ich
habe meinen key pass auf dem streaming rechner und es reicht fertig du kannst mit zwei faktor
authentifizierung absichern ja bestimmt bestimmt wie gesagt du kannst also es gibt ja zwei
grundsätzliche ansätze entweder du sagst ok ich will das ins internet packen weil ich
zugriff drauf brauche und dann versuchst du es so dicht wie möglich zu machen oder
so schwierig wie möglich irgendwie dran kommen dran zu kommen oder die viel bessere variante
ist sich überlegen brauche ich da wirklich zugriff von außen für und wenn man nicht
unbedingt zugriff von außen für braucht dann ist einfach nicht machen weil dann muss
man sich das auch nicht zu bauen und dicht machen und sonst wo dort wo es keinen zugriff
gibt und da wo die sachen nicht liegen kann damit auch keiner was machen key pass funktioniert
nicht mit mehreren leuten ja das kenne ich key pass ist gerade also wir hatten auch mal
eine weile früher ein key pass auf eine windows laufwerk das funktioniert nicht richtig aber
das finde ich echt nützlich hier das hat was finde ich wirklich cool gemacht aber wie
gesagt ich werde wahrscheinlich bei bei pass bleiben das ist der screenshot screenshot
aus dem report zeigt mal her
auch noch den server key eingecheckt besonders clever tja keine allzu gute idee würde ich
mal sagen
weil die sind wahrscheinlich nicht auf github weil github zu zu microsoft ist
das ist das ist ob das stimmt sei mal dahingestellt aber die antwort ist in ordnung ich würde
es trotzdem nicht einchecken
hier haben wir richtig cloud native leute wieder am start ich betreibe volt warn on
prem in kombination mit wire guard ja also on prem bett ich betreibe übrigens auch wollte
ich jetzt nur mal erwähnen ich betreibe gerade mit worden auch on prem weil es ist einfach
auch besser als lokal klingt cooler gebe ich dir recht ja also mit wire also mit vpn dass
das super funst will ich gar nicht in frage stellen das funktioniert sicherlich super
wenn man zugriff von unterwegs braucht wäre das auch mein bevorzugte variante entweder
über open vpn oder wire guard würde ich genauso machen also würde ich würde ich genauso machen
aber wenn man dann wirklich sagt man braucht den zugriff eigentlich gar nicht von außen
dann ist das beste weil lässt es dicht und kann sich alles sparen es abzusichern weil
was nicht auf ist muss da nicht absichern das ist einfach nicht da lokal private cloud
und das ist natürlich auch gut private cloud on prem private cloud
ja die haben wahrscheinlich einfach nicht die hoch bezahlten sap consultants wie die
corona app da kann sowas schon mal passieren ja aber das ist trotzdem fail das erste was
ich mache ist eigentlich also auch wenn es irgendwelche projekte sind die für microcontroller
mit wlan secrets und sonst was das erste was ich mache ist ich mache eine extra secrets
datei und pack die ins git ignore oder noch besser die dateien mit den keys gar nicht
erst im gleichen ordner haben wo das git repo ist das kellerkenntnis am start fünf
monat dankeschön für den sap so warte mal ich muss mal kurz in mein dashboard gucken
hab bestimmt ein paar saps überlesen das habe ich mich übrigens schon die ganze zeit
gefragt warum man das nicht einfach in die corona app einbaut an der elf monate eins
vor hyper subscription hier danke für den sap eins habe ich gegen das wert sieben hat
subscrib dankeschön und star meg sechs monate huge saps leute hier zwei habe ich übersehen
vorhin was machst du dann würde ich das nicht unbedingt in dem git repo machen sondern du
kannst ja oftmals also bei github actions ist es so da kannst du secrets in deinem also
an der anderen stelle hinterlegen und kannst sie dann referenzieren aus deinem bild bild
jammel also du musst das dann nicht in das gleiche repo legen sondern du kannst das quasi
als als variabel drauf zugreifen guckt sie dann so aus
secret wir haben sogar mal wir haben das sogar mal im stream gemacht zusammen secret genau
hier du gehst du gehst in das in das in das in das projekt ich glaube es geht auch account
weit legst das secret hinzu also sprich das secret kommt nicht in das git repo rein und
dann kannst du in deine action kannst du verlinken auf diesen example key genau hier guck super
secret dollar secrets kannst du verlinken also so machst du das zumindest mit github actions
also sprich dass du das password erst gar nicht einschränken musst wie gesagt github actions
geht es auch das geht ja das geht ja hier übrigens auch ne also ich habe jetzt hier
mein token im klartext reingeschrieben das würde ich in normalerweise nicht so machen
du kannst ja auch du kannst hier oben in secrets secrets anlegen dann ich krieg das aus dem
kopf jetzt nicht zusammen sondern nimmst du kannst in ein feil irgendwie reinschreiben
secrets punkt key oder was auch immer und dann kannst du darauf dass dann quasi hier
drauf zugreifen und ich glaube dieses feilen muss noch nicht mal im gleichen repo liegen
also es ist auch es ist auch da möglich darauf zuzugreifen ohne dass man das einschätzt so
so wo wir gerade dabei sind wollten wir nicht das video gucken wo linus torwalz über linux
desktop lestat ok das video ist aber schon ein bisschen älter also das ist anscheinend
debian konfigur konfigur es geht auch nur elf minuten debian konferenz von 2014 2014
war er noch nicht reformed ich weiß nicht wer es mitgekriegt hat der hat ja vor einer
weile mal einen post gemacht auf der linux mailing liste also die sind ja also das ist
ja alles ein bisschen old school damit er noch per mailing listen und so sachen gemacht und
da hat er gesagt er zieht sich jetzt eine weile aus der mailing liste zurück und wird
an sich arbeiten dass er nicht mehr so oft schimpft der ging ja teilweise hat er schon
übelst krass gerantet teilweise oftmals mit grund ist es gar nicht so dass man sagen
könnte der hat einfach nur geflammt um des flamens willen der hatte schon immer der
hatte schon immer dann einen wahren punkt und die finden sind ja auch dafür bekannt
dass die im alltag viel flamen habe ich mir sagen lassen von dem dene weiß ich ob das
stimmt aber ich glaube dass dem einfach mal also finnische umgangsform sind wohl recht
grau und dementsprechend dass deswegen ist er da immer am meckern gewesen und das heißt
der vortrag ist von 2014 das bedeutet das kann durchaus sein dass der öfters mal sagt
mal gucken vielleicht brauchen wir den fuck counter oder scam train ist am start leute
eins hat noch lasst euch noch mal scam nils fps dankeschön für acht monate subs gibt
jeff noch ein bisschen geld da braucht unbedingt noch mehr kohle aber ich krieg ja immerhin
die hälfte ab also gibt ihr quasi macht ihr jeff noch reicher und mich auch wobei ich
bei mir nicht von reich sprechen würde captain pitt dankeschön fürs prime prime gaming
ha ich wollte ich nicht auslachen sorry falsches falscher knopf aber wenn du nicht die bett
lasst das ich wollte jetzt ab square button drücken so also gucken wir uns das mal an
gucken wir uns mal wieder am flamen ist also ist laut genug 480 b das sagt alles über
linux konferenzen im jahr 2014 ich meine ich habe man darf nicht vergessen man darf
nicht vergessen ich habe 2010 gameplay hochgeladen 720p 60 fps das ist 2014 unter linux noch
nicht möglich war kann er ja verstehen ja so ist ok doch youtube hatte relativ schnell
60 fps ganz am anfang das stimmt ganz am anfang nicht das ist richtig aber ich habe
ziemlich schnell 60 fps hochgeladen als es dann ging und außerdem 4 zu 3 warum ist das
fucking 4 zu 3 na egal das kannst du vergessen unterlinux snap snap damals wusste er noch
nicht was auf ihn zukommt snap der hat da gar nicht gedacht der hat gedacht es wird
besser aber wirklich kein foot ist noch schlimmer das stimmt das gibt es das gibt es das gibt
es wenig das ist ja heute immer noch so ja ok fucking counter nummer eins ich wusste
da kommt ein paar fuckings dabei das geht nicht anders er hat nicht unrecht wobei das
ein bisschen wobei das ein bisschen ich meine natürlich hat er nicht unrecht er ist also
wenn er wenn einer weiß was bei linux sache ist dann eher aber es ist in den letzten sechs
jahren hat sich sechs sieben jahren hat schon ein bisschen was getan in die richtung dank
docker und go ist das mit binaries für linux viel einfacher und besser geworden also mit
binaries zu erzeugen ist easy as fuck und mit docker anwendung zu packagen ist auch
deutlich einfacher als früher also ein bisschen zum besseren hat sich gewendet es kam allerdings
auch so komische sachen wie snap und so dabei da ja das ist der teufel in persone
ist
Binary's for Debian Stable, actually you don't make Binary's for Debian Stable, because Debian Stable has
Libraries that are so old, that anything that was built in the last century doesn't work, right?
Das geile ist, das ist eine Debian-Konferenz.
Whatever the code name is for for unstable and
Es war Debian geflammt.
We had this small local flanefest just a couple of days ago,
Debian has these rules that you're supposed to use
shared libraries, right? And if you don't use shared libraries,
getting your package in like it's just painful.
But using shared libraries is not an option when the library...
mit Docker gebessert, für Sachen, Packagen
und mit Go hast du das Problem nicht mehr.
Mit Go, kompiliertes Binary läuft rückwärts kompatibel
auf jedem Linux-Kernel bis kernel 2.6.16 oder so.
App-Images sind auch okay.
Das Problem, was er anspricht, ist aber immer noch da.
Man hat es ein bisschen umschifft mit Container-Packaging
und dass es viele Go-Bineries gibt.
App-Image ist im Prinzip ein ähnlicher Gedanke.
Man macht es ähnlich wie unter Windows.
Jede Anwendung bringt seinen eigenen Kram mit,
worauf er sich nicht verlassen kann, dass es da ist.
Unter Windows hast du den Vorteil, dass die System-Bineries an sich,
also die System-Libraries, da weißt du, dass die da sind
und wie man die anspricht, und die ändert sich auch nicht alle drei Tage mal.
Das Problem hast du, wie gesagt, prinzipiell unter Linux immer noch,
gerade weil solche Basic-Libraries, wie irgendwelche C-Sachen,
sich nicht nur entweder komplett unterscheiden können.
Es gibt ja noch nicht nur die libc-Standardgeschichten,
sondern noch andere, die man theoretisch auch verwenden könnte.
Und dann kommt noch die Version dazu und sonst was.
Das Problem hast du immer noch, und das hast du hauptsächlich unter Linux,
das hast du nicht so sehr unter Windows und web,
und man umgeht das eben mit self-contained-Bineries, App-Images,
Docker-Packages und so umgeht man das halt nur.
Man hat dann aber auch die gleichen Probleme im Prinzip wie unter Windows,
dass da jeder seine eigenen Sachen mitbringt.
Ich finde es aber auch in der heutigen Zeit nicht schlecht.
Ich finde es nicht übel.
Früher konnte man sagen, ja, okay, wenn du es über den Paketmanager installierst,
musst du halt von der Library immer nur eine Version installiert haben,
anstatt dass jede von deinen 15 Anwendungen die eigene hat.
Also zum Beispiel eine Library, die super beliebt dafür war,
ist zip-library.
Ihr fragt mich nicht, wie die Standards libzip oder so heißt.
Zlip, Zlip meine ich, genau.
Also Zlip ist so eine Sache, die war früher,
oder SQLite ist auch so eine Sache, die total oft gebundelt wurde.
Also unter Windows hast du dann halt 15 Anwendungen,
jeder bringt seine SQLite mit und jeder bringt eine andere Version Zlip mit.
Unter Linux war das halt die ganze Zeit nicht so.
Da hast du über den Package-Manager hast du deine Version X installiert
und alles musst du dann halt aufbauen auf Version X.
Das ist aber wie er sagt schon pain in the ass.
Für Portierbarkeit ist das nicht so schön.
Und jetzt, wie macht man das unter Linux?
Ja gut, man macht mit App-Image, Docker oder Self-Contained,
Go Binaries, machst du im Prinzip das.
Du packst alles mit ein, was du brauchst und hast dabei,
also du hast es im Prinzip so ähnlich wie unter Mac oder auf Windows jetzt.
Außer das, was du über den Package-Manager installierst.
Also Problem gibt's, da hat er voll und ganz recht auch 2021 noch.
Wow, ein Linux-Streamer, bin ich dabei.
Exzellent.
Schön, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast.
Pferd, Korall.
Setge.
Richtig Setge.
Das stimmt, da sind die sogar richtig gut drin.
Das muss man ihnen mal sagen.
Also das Kernel-Interface, das funktioniert wirklich gut.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum du Go Binaries laufen lassen kannst.
Also wenn du jetzt ein Go-Binary machst und kopierst das auf ein Kernel 2.6.16 oder so zurück,
das läuft noch und das geht nur, weil das stable ist.
Ich meine, irgendeine Mindestversion musst du dich mal drauf festlegen, was du nimmst.
Ja, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, es war irgendein 2.6.16 Kernel Mindestversion,
wo Go Binaries drauf laufen.
2.6, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein 2.6.16 oder so, 2.6.23, nicht 2.6.16, okay.
Leute, ich habe mich vertan, ich habe 2.6.16 gesagt und es ist 2.6.23 gewesen.
Anzeige ist raus.
Ja, und das kriegen die wirklich gut hin.
Das muss man ihnen wirklich lassen.
Okay, Shit, Shit, Shit, Fuck und Stupid Counter, wir sind glaube ich schon bei A5 oder
so.
Ich finde das geil.
Aber wie gesagt, die Konferenz war noch, bevor er sich selbst reformt hat.
Ja, das NVIDIA Mittelfinger Video gibt es auch noch.
Also I Crushed You bedeutet bei ihm, er schreibt einen 2 Seiten Mailing-Listen-Post, in dem
er ihn komplett zur Sau macht.
Wobei, wie gesagt, er ist ja reformt mittlerweile.
Und ja, ich möchte ihm auch noch mal Recht geben an der Stelle.
Es ist 2021 immer noch so und man sieht es bei GTK wunderbar, du kannst GTK eigentlich
nicht verwenden, außer Gnome selbst oder sagen wir so Gnome-only-Anwendungen, die auch
aktiv oft gepflegt werden.
Du kannst GTK nicht verwenden, GTK geht laufend kaputt.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum keiner GTK Cross-Platformen programmiert, obwohl das prinzipiell funktioniert.
GTK läuft ja eigentlich auch auf Windows.
GTK geht immer kaputt, wenn die Gnome-Leute der Meinung sind, ah das machen wir jetzt
ein bisschen anders.
Immer.
Deswegen benutzt keiner GTK so wirklich für Cross-Platform-Sachen.
Ist Inkscape GTK unter Windows?
Also VLC sieht ja auch nicht schön aus, hat aber vor einer Weile umgestellt von GTK auf
Qt.
Die machen es besser.
Ja, so lange wie niemand es bemerkt, aber sofort, wenn jemand es bemerkt, ist es eine schlechte
Sache.
Und das ist ein großer Deal für den Kern und ich habe viel劲, die Entwickler zu erklären,
dass das eine wirklich, wirklich wichtige Sache ist.
Und dann kommen all die Verteilungen rein und schreien sie alles auf.
Denn sie brechen die Binary-Kompatibilität links und rechts, sie update Glib-C und alles
brechen.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Hat er nicht unrecht, ja.
Ich werde nicht sogar in alle anderen Libräten kommen, aber es ist wirklich traurig, wenn
die meisten Core-Libräten im ganzen System mit dem Bremsen in Ordnung sind und so lange
wie Dinge verbessern und sie die ABI fixieren.
Also das ist mein Ramp.
Und das ist das, was ich wirklich fundamentalistisch denke, dass es sich ändern muss, für Linux
auf dem Desktop zu arbeiten.
Nein, das hat man 2014 eventuell gedacht, leider gaben selbst nicht in der Lage, da
was zu machen.
Es ist eigentlich nicht, weil ich denke, dass Spiele wichtig sind, ich habe keine Ahnung,
ich spiele keine Spiele.
Ich denke, dass manche Menschen das tun, also Spiele sind vielleicht wichtig.
Aber das wirklich wichtige Thema ist, ich garantiere euch, Valve wird nicht 15 verschiedene
Binary-Kompatibilitäten machen.
Und ich garantiere euch auch, dass jede einzelne Desktop-Distribution sich um Valve und Binary-Kompatibilitäten
umfasst.
Und dann ist Steam 200 MB groß oder so, was glaube ich ja auch ist.
Ich meine, Steam kann das insofern auch machen, Steam ist ja unter der Haube im Prinzip erstmal
nur ein Browser, also das Frontend, das ist irgendein Embedded-Chrome-Gedöns.
Und das bringen die mit, plus halt alles, was es braucht, um zu laufen.
Und das ist ein bisschen traurig, aber das ist das, was ihr jetzt tun müsst.
Ich würde gerne zurückkommen zu dem Thema, dass die Applikation auf jeder Distribution
funktioniert.
Und das mit den drei Modulen im Kern, wo die Regel ist, das Modul im Kern zu bekommen,
könnte man vielleicht das gleiche für die Applikation fragen, um die Modul in zwei Distributionen
zu bekommen.
Ich denke, das ist das, was ganz oft passiert, ich meine, das ist das, was die meisten...
Okay, der Rant ist fertig, die Fragerunde müssen wir uns nicht mehr angucken, oder?
Der Rant ist fertig.
Ja, da hat er natürlich auch 2021 immer noch recht mit, ja.
Oh, guck mal, oh nee, 44 Minuten, 44 Minuten gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Da kommt noch ein Rant, okay, okay.
Oh, Was geht's, ach so!
Also, diese Nummern sind nicht komplett ausgestattet, aber mein Punkt ist,
wenn du 10 User auf Debian und 10 User auf Fedora hast,
und ich weiß, dass wir ein paar User auf Arch haben.
Die Linux-User scheinen an Ubuntu zu sein.
Das macht eigentlich einen Sinn,
weil die Diver nicht unbedingt komputertechnische Leute sind.
Und Ubuntu hat so eine Art Crowd verkauft.
Wenn man so eine Situation hat,
dann macht es keinen Sinn,
dass die Leute in jeder Distribution
diese App für diese Distribution packen
und das so in einer wirklich zeitgenössischen Art machen.
Die Veränderungen sind wirklich wichtig für die User,
denn ohne diese Veränderungen kann der Dive-Computer nicht funktionieren.
Nein, das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Auch für Open-Source-Projekte, die das Projekt in ein Projekt wie Debian bringen,
ist einfach ein Verlust der Mannschaft.
Ihr habt bessere Dinge zu tun.
Vertragt mich, ihr habt es wirklich.
Ein paar Fun-Applikationen, aber niemand sollte ihre Leben verlusten.
Oh, vielleicht ist der Verluster hier.
Aber der Punkt ist,
ich bin dankbar, dass wir einen Debian-Maintainer haben.
Hab ich das kaputt gemacht?
Debian-Maintainer sind teilweise komische Leute.
Das kann ich euch jetzt nicht erzählen,
weil da müsste ich erzählen, wo ich damals gearbeitet habe.
Ja.
ranking
Das ist heute tatsächlich deutlich besser.
deutlich besser geworden, wenn man das, wenn das in irgendeinem Container liegt oder als App Image oder als Go
Binary oder so. Das ist dann zwar natürlich groß, weil das alles mitbringt, was es braucht zum Laufen oder als.NET
.NET Core Self-Contained Anwendung oder so. Das ist tatsächlich insofern besser.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so, wie er es gemeint hat damals, dass es werden muss, aber das Problem ist besser geworden.
Erstmal Chrome kompilieren. Habt ihr schon mal versucht, Chrome zu kompilieren, Chet? Also ich hab's schon gemacht. Es ist nicht schön.
Da brauchst du erstmal 50 Gigabyte RAM, 200G Festplatte und musst 50 Post-Pre-Build-Steps machen.
Und dann kompiliert es da auch noch lange. Ich find's geil. Erstmal die Idee, wie man Leute flamen kann.
Du kannst das auch in einem Docker-Computer kompilieren. Das ist wahrscheinlich sogar besser.
Du kannst dir auch einen fetten Cloud-Surfer mieten mit 48 Kernen, um Chrome zu kompilieren.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall Paints-Champ und du brauchst richtig viel RAM und auch Plattenplatz dafür, dass du das machen kannst.
Ich hab jetzt einfach mal 50G RAM gesagt. Wahrscheinlich reichen auch 20G, aber du brauchst auf jeden Fall viel.
Es war definitiv zu viel für meine VM. Und meine VM hat ja schon mal hier, hat ja nur 16G. Also 16G hat nicht gereicht an RAM zum Chrome kompilieren.
Was muss ich unter Chrome kompilieren verstehen? Du lädst dir den Source Code von Chrome runter. Das ist auch eine ganze Ecke.
Es gibt auch so ein How-To. Get-Code-Checkout. Step-by-Step-Checking-Building-Chrome.
Ja, das musst du alles machen. Du checkst dir das Chrome-Repo aus und dann kompilierst du den, dass am Ende ein fertiger Chrome rauskommt.
Das braucht viel RAM und das dauert lange.
Ich mein, machen muss man es nicht, aber ich weiß gar nicht mehr, weshalb wollten wir das damals machen.
Ich glaube, ich weiß wieder, warum wir Chrome kompilieren wollten, wegen GPU-Decoding von Videos.
Es war damals so experimental, dass es nur mit einem selbst kompilierten Chrome überhaupt funktioniert hat.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es mittlerweile funktioniert richtig. Wahrscheinlich immer noch nicht.
Um Chrome zu bilden, brauchst du Perl-Ruby-Python installiert. Ich übertreibe jetzt mal ein bisschen.
Du musst 50 Pre-Build-Stritte machen und dann kannst du es versuchen zu kompilieren.
Schön ist es nicht. Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen. Ich habe Hunger.
Wir sehen uns morgen früh zum Aufwachen-Stream. Schön, dass ihr dabei wart. Danke für die ganzen Subs.
Wir sehen uns bis dann. Macht es gut.
Schauen wir mal, ob ich jemand hosten kann.
Oh, keiner da.
Gibt es zu Futter und Brötchen?
Ach egal, ich gucke jetzt nicht weiter. Ich gehe jetzt auf, Leute. Wir sehen uns bis dann.